well social media video shows that
witnesses believed police had killed the
wrong person when they shot a black man
at an Alabama shopping mall on
Thanksgiving three gunshot victims can
be seen in the video including EJ
Bradford Hoover police have offered
shifting explanations for why they
mistook Bradford for an active shooter
protesters gathered last night at the
mayor's home to demand answers
mark Strassmann is outside police
headquarters in Hoover south of
Birmingham mark good morning good
morning we've been pushing for answers
in this shooting but state investigators
say they won't comment on an active case
and Hoover police despite a pledge of
transparency never got back to us in
their latest statement they insisted
that Bradford was holding his gun when
they first responded at the mall witness
video shows the aftermath EJ Bradford
shot by police at the River chase
Galleria Mall police in Bradford was
armed the 21 year old had a legal
concealed weapons permit at first police
in Hoover Alabama insisted he had
wounded two people earlier at the mall
they quickly backpedaled Bradford was
not the gunman the real gunman remains
at large at Birmingham 16th Street
Baptist Church a civil rights landmark
the Bradford family's anger and
frustration was shared by several
hundred supporters it was too much for
April Pipkins the victim's mother she
collapsed in
humanik Bradford senior is his father I
got a bear of my baby boy and it hurts
me to the core because being at home
every day hate will be no fun cuz that
kicked up but yeah
Bradford family attorney Ben Crump
argues ej was killed because police saw
a black man holding a gun there's some
suggestion that to stop the bad guys
with guns we need to have the good guys
with guns
well EJ Bradford was a good guy with a
good
[Applause]
Bradford's family is demanding the
release of all videos from the shooting
at the mall including whatever was
recorded by the shooting officers body
camera witnesses have told the family
that Bradford was trying to guide
bystanders to safety when he was shot
Gail when you're around his parents
you can feel just how raw their pain is
I know Martin we all feel it here in the
studio the mom passing out for grief the
dad who was a who is a police officer
was a police officer and I think the
attorney make bench Benjamin Crump makes
a good point you know people say good
guy with a gun he was a good guy with a
gun who was trained yeah an army veteran
they should release that video and it
should be transparency that's cuz we all
need to learn from this what ours are
implicit bias about this story there's a
lot more on this story I think an
interesting nor that they won't release
a video that says a lot